hey 42 here if you're like me you'll
sometimes wonder what it must be like to
be rich and I'm not talking about flying
first class and staying in luxury hotels
rich I mean taking a private jet to the
hotel you just bought so you can have a
gold toilet installed in your Penthouse
rich
[Music]
few of us will ever experience that kind
of excessive wealth but there's
something undeniably fascinating about
the super rich it's almost as if they're
a different species they may look like
us well us with much better clothes and
the kind of skin you only get from
bathing in Evian but they're
fundamentally different it's almost like
a person's Behavior gets odder as his or
her income increases can you the more
money you have the harder it is for
people to say no to you and there are
few bigger Bank balances than that of a
billionaire there are numerous examples
of those with the deepest of pockets
doing the strangest of things from Elon
Musk sending that car into orbit to the
time Mr Burns tried to block out the sun
why do billionaires have such a weird
compulsion to mess about with space
anyway for the most mind-bogglingly
wealthy and Bonkers billionaire there
has ever been you need to go back long
before Tesla Anderson
may I introduce you to the weird world
of Howard Robert Hughes Jr a plain
flying filmmaking adventure-loving
germ-fearing entrepreneur and easily the
most eccentric billionaire who's ever
lived
[Music]
Howard Hughes Jr was born in 1905 in
Houston Texas the son of Howard Hughes
senior a wealthy inventor and
businessman who made his fortune by
patenting a fancy kind of drill bit that
might not sound like the business idea
to spawn one of History's wealthiest men
but this was no ordinary hardware store
drill accessory
Howard Hughes seniors two cone rotary
drill bit revolutionized the drilling of
oil wells during the Texas oil boom of
the early 20th century
in other words it was practically a
license to print money and Little Howard
grew up with all the things a boy could
want not that he was just some cuddled
rich kid though from a very young age he
demonstrated an impressive engineering
Talent all of his own
his dad set up a workshop in a shed
behind their house and at 12 Hughes
Junior made what was described in the
local papers as the first motorized
bicycle in Houston by taking parts from
a steam engine and adding them to his
bike
perfectly normal run-of-the-mill 12 year
old boy stuff playing games outside with
your friends starting to fancy people at
school turning steam engines into
prototype motorbikes the usual
despite his undeniable engineering
Excellence Howard wasn't a great student
and his parents sent him off to a fancy
private school in Boston in the hope
that he would later go to Harvard as
Hugh senior had done however Howard's
academic record didn't really improve
whilst he was away but he did get really
bloody good at golf
he also underwent one of the greatest
epiphanies of his life when first on
board an airplane he instantly fell in
love with the feeling of flying and a
lifelong obsession with Aviation began
[Music]
Howard's upbringing reads like some kind
of quaint British fairy tale that's
undergone Financial doping but the good
times are about to come to a swift end
when he was 16 his mother died during
pregnancy and two years later his father
passed away after suffering a heart
attack at 18 Howard was suddenly an
orphan and obscenely Rich often but an
orphan nonetheless in 1925 he inherited
75 of his father's million dollar estate
that's over 16 million dollars today and
a large stake in the family business
Hughes tool company with the other
shares going to his relatives
almost immediately Howard disagreed with
them about how the company should be run
but he couldn't do anything about it as
he wouldn't legally be an adult until he
was 21. so when he turned 19 he went to
court and got a judge to declare him an
emancipated minor that's a minor as in a
child not as in a person who digs
although given the tools they were
making I technically he was both a
ruling meant that he was now officially
an adult and he promptly bought out all
of his relatives until he owns the
company outright whether this maneuver
made him a dynamic Captain of industry
he was wise Beyond his years or a
precocious little with no loyalty
is up for discussion but it certainly
set a precedent for how he'd conduct
business for the rest of his life
the same year he assumed full control of
fused tools Howard married his first
wife Ella rice but he wasn't happy with
simply being a filthy rich tool magnate
and the couple relocated to La so Howard
could pursue his twin passions of
filmmaking and flying the flying got off
to a flying start he was a natural but
the filmmaking fell flat the first short
film he financed was such a disaster
that he ordered every print in existence
to be destroyed but gradually he started
to have some success in 1930 he produced
Hell's Angels which isn't about large
hairy men polishing their motorbikes but
as a tale of heroic World War One flying
Aces the movie was a mammoth production
that was three years in the making
largely because it's many epic dogfights
were all filmed for real this was a time
when health and safety protocols were
very much optional and free stunt pilots
and a mechanic were killed during
filming
with the death toll mounting the film's
final stunt was deemed too dangerous to
even attempt but as Howard was now an
experienced pilot he decided to have a
go at it himself
he was a brave but ultimately rather
foolish decision he crashed during the
maneuver fracturing his skull in the
process
but the near-death experience put him
off flying quite the opposite in 1934 he
founded the Hughes aircraft company
which produced several experimental
planes that he tested himself
the first of which was the Hughes H1
racer and in 1935 Howard broke the ward
land plane speed record whilst flying it
though in what was fast becoming a bad
habit the record flight ended with a
crash landing this time he walked away
with nothing more than a few cuts and
scrapes
Howard's Aviation Obsession would see
him set several other records over the
following years and he also oversaw the
production of the H4 Hercules better
known by its nickname the Spruce Goose
to this day it Remains the largest
seaplane ever built
[Music]
at this point in his life Howard was an
almost superhero-like figure he was tall
and fearless good looking a super rich
businessman and a genius engineer if
that's ringing any bells you might not
be surprised to learn that Hughes was
actually Stanley's inspiration for Tony
Stark
like Iron Man Howard also loved the
company of beautiful women he's married
to Ella only lasted four years and once
he was a single man again being young
handsome and absolutely Filthy Rich he
didn't find female company hard to come
by in the 30s and 40s he dated a string
of the most glamorous movie stars of the
day including Catherine Hepburn Ava
Gardner Joan Crawford Betty Davies and
Ginger Rogers
the outbreak of World War II saw a huge
aircraft secure lucrative contracts to
build military planes but despite
millions of dollars from the US
government only free were ever delivered
now I'm no military historian but I'm
pretty sure you need more than that to
fight a crowd of Black Friday Shoppers
let alone a walk offering half the
planet the government felt the same way
and Howard was hauled in front of the
Senate commission accused of gross
mismanagement but something much worse
than a grilling from a group of Aging
politicians was waiting around the
corner one of the plane's Hughes
aircraft had been meant to produce
during the war was the xf-11 a
reconnaissance craft in July
1946 a prototype was finally ready
better later never a and naturally it
was Howard who took it out for a spin on
its first flight but like the Titanic
the xf-11s made in mission was to end in
disaster
Midway through the flights the plane
sprung a leak and subsequently crashed
into the wealthy LA suburb of Beverly
Hills destroying free houses as it went
down
Howard was pulls from the wreckage
moments before the entire thing
obliterated in a fireball but although
his life was saved he was badly injured
in the crash suffering for degree burns
a collapsed lung and multiple cracked
rips his recovery was slow necessitating
mumps in hospital during which time he
was given a high concentration of
opioids for the constant pain it proved
to be a turning point in his life and
from then on drugs would forever play a
role in his day-to-day existence
despite the huge personal setback
business was booming Hughes was a modern
day Midas and his golden touch soon made
him the richest man in America he
expanded his Empire by purchasing a
controlling stake in Transworld Airlines
and building a missile plant on a 6 000
acre plot near Tuscan Arizona his
business Acumen and lack of moral served
him well and he did things which your
other more one-of-the-mill billionaires
didn't dare for example he set up the
Howard Hughes Medical Institute in 1953.
this charitable Foundation undertook
medical research and as soon as it was
up and running Howard transferred all of
the stock from Hughes aircraft into it
as a result one of the world's biggest
defense contractors was exempt from
paying any tax almost overnight
sneaky in 1957 he married his second
wife the actress Jean Peters but away
from the public eye his Antics were
becoming increasingly erratic and by
erratic I actually mean flinging
mental he once stayed in a darkened film
studio for four months straight rarely
wearing clothes and eating only
chocolate bars and chicken
he spends his time there watching the
same films over and over again whilst
rearranging the dozens of tissue boxes
he kept nearby at all times as for
whether they were sad tissues or happy
tissues I assume that depended on the
film Hughes had always been eccentric
and to some this kind of behavior with
evidence he'd finally gone to Gaga land
but the truth was much sadder than that
Hughes had always suffered from
crippling OCD and an extreme fear of
germs conditions that eventually
consumed his life
these kinds of illnesses are
debilitating no matter who you are but
Hughes incredible wealth and influence
meant he could give his compulsive
behaviors free reign
he was known to incinerate his entire
wardrobe whenever he fought too many
germs had made their home in his
favorite outfits and he wouldn't even
talk to people if they had so much of a
Speck of lint on their clothes
he washed his hands to the points that
they bled and in later years he rarely
wore clothes at all because doing so
caused him physical pain
after years of living alone in a
bungalow with the luxurious Beverly
Hills Hotel Howard moved to Las Vegas in
1966. there he settled in the penthouse
of the Desert Inn whilst the entire
floor below became a base of operations
for his vast Empire after a year of
living in the hotel during which time he
didn't ever leave it he simply bought it
outright it would be the first of many
purchases in Vegas during the course of
two years Hughes bought more hotels and
casinos than any other investor in the
city's history amongst them was the
Silver Slipper Casino which had as its
sign a large rotating neon slipper
Howard could see it from his Penthouse
and The Shining shoe apparently kept him
awake at night
after the hotel's owners refused to
switch it off Hughes bought them out for
a ludicrous sum just so he could get rid
of the sign
he became such a recluse that in 1970
Gene filed for divorce claiming that for
years she'd only ever spoken to her
husband over the phone by this point he
had little to do with the running of his
business Empire the day-to-day decisions
were being made by a small group of
advisors then Howard vacated Vegas in
the early 70s and lived out his final
years in another luxury hotel which he
bought in the Bahamas almost nobody saw
him in those days as he was slowly
consumed by mental illness he hardly
ever cut his hair beard or nails and
when he died in 1974 he was so
unrecognizable from the swashbuckling
industrialist of years past that the FBI
had to use fingerprints to make sure the
body was really his
it was a deeply sad end to an at-time
brilliant life and an important reminder
that good health is a treasure we just
can't put a price on before illness
robbed him of his reason how it lived
life to the fullest making millions
breaking records producing movies and
swanning about of the hottest babes in
the Golden Age of Hollywood
to get to do any one of these things
would have been incredible
to do all of them in a single lifetime
now that really does take something
special
[Music]
thanks for watching